Hello, everyone. Ashley here and the holiday season is approaching all of us, which means
a few things. You're probably experiencing some anxiety, some stress, but I really hope
you don't leave out how excited you are as well. The bigger question is, is are you ready?
Are you physically, mentally, spiritually and emotionally ready for the holiday season?
Depending on if you're hosting or not, you might have some more work to do than others. Maybe
you're traveling, maybe you are decorating the house, and you have dinner to prepare.
But regardless what your stressors are for the holiday, we all have our daily life on
top of all of that as well. So how are you going to do it? Just make sure you don't burn yourself
out this holiday season so then at the end, you can enjoy it. So what do you get for the
holidays then? You might get some stress, some fatigue, anxiety, maybe you have some mood swings,
and maybe you can't sleep. None of that sounds like a gift to me, but how did that even happen to
you? You got stuck in a sympathetic state. So you got put in the fight mode instead of the flight
mode, the sympathetic versus parasympathetic. And what happens when you're stuck in that sympathetic
state is your body fights for so long to have you go, go, go, that you're releasing so much adrenaline.
And your cortisol levels change, you produce more stress and fatigue, your thyroid gets damaged,
your adrenaline glands cannot keep up, you're constantly outputting more than replenishing,
and you're not able to relax, and your adrenaline, adrenals cannot balance out. What happened was
you weren't able to adapt to the environment, all of those external stress factors you were faced
with, you were just not able to adapt to it and balance it out. And to prevent you from the shutting
down phase after the holidays is over, you should think of adaptogens. Adaptogens are what will help you
adapt to your environment. So while you're going through all these stressors during the holiday season,
this will help you normalize and balance everything out. So adaptogens are a non-toxic
herb, and they support your body's reaction to these stressors. They help calm you down,
and then they help give you energy at the same time. So this particularly helps in your adrenal
system with the thyroid, the adrenal glands, and the pituitary. And then it helps you counteract
the adverse effects of the stress. And then your body is able to support its immune system,
and also help you with your mood and your mental performance as well.
So this gives you an overall stress support for your whole body, and then what happens with
your immune system then is it doesn't make it work as hard. So once you go, go, go, your immune system
starts to be compromised, and so you also want to keep in mind you need to support that as well,
to prevent from getting sick after your big show of the holidays is over.
So a good adaptogens support is adaptogen R3. The ingredients are found here on the right hand side,
and all of these are those non-toxic herbs that I mentioned just a minute ago. And those will help
normalize your body into a balanced form of combating your stress factors. This will help with
the anxiety that gets created. It can help you balance, so then you're able to sleep well.
And all of those are important, so then you're able to function for your holiday season.
If you click the adaptogen R3 right here, this link will bring you right to a page where you are
able to purchase that adaptogen support. So the holidays should be fun, and with the supporting
your body with adaptogens, you're able to say goodbye to stress, goodbye to your immune swings,
goodbye to fatigue, goodbye anxiety, and then you'll be able to have a lot of fun at their
family because you're working so hard to make this the best holiday that it can be. Thank you for
listening to my presentation.